[Music]
in fishing for compliments oh my god
that's me all the time please tell me
I'm pretty
you're pretty easy that's not fishing
for compliments you just asked for a
dude you have to be like oh my god I'm
so ugly no you're a hundred percent
right let's go you catch the wrong fish
dirty boot off the water did shave on
the dirty boot yield you're gonna be
with your face on it you've got a tin
can
submitted by God Tyr trash China's new a
social media craze is to pay people to
shower you with over-the-top compliments
oh yeah hey people I like it well cuz
Chinese people are gonna compliment each
other yeah so you got to pay for other
people they need an incentive to be nice
oh I would [ __ ] Photoshop the [ __ ]
out my picture to little [ __ ] gross
ass [ __ ] everything I say something nice
say something real nice about this yeah
is it BOTS is it which other Chinese
people or is it like there's always
source to Indian okay yeah like
everything gets outsourced to India it's
just a bunch of Indian people like yeah
you look oh nice dress I would much
rather have an Indian person compliment
me than a Chinese person
why because I feel like Indians would
shower me with love and in the Chinese
person would be like hey you have the A+
today hey big big head you have such a
smart brain yeah it's like a backhanded
compliment yeah yeah the Indian was like
you're beautiful your eyes are so
straight for ugly face
gosh you're only with the mobile quality
yeah so this is happening on social
media site and messaging platforms like
we chat and Weibo and WeChat so it's not
even like public it's just like to get
personal compliments yeah so what
happens here is that you pay money to
join a praising group or they call it
qua qua one
I think thanks for slaughtering the
language wrong hold on anyway so uh
certain so different groups have
different payment systems so for example
this one person he charges 15 you want
or $2 and 23 cents for three minutes or
25 yuan or which is three dollars
seventy two minutes for five minutes of
praise and so you end up adding you to
this group and then all these people for
a determinate like however much time you
pay or it depends that they have a
different method of doing things yet
they end up just showering you with
compliments so you get to pretty much
tell them details about yourself man
your relationship or someone like other
likes or dislikes cuz you could pay for
someone else to join the group so like
as a gift
I'll give like something you tell these
people like oh this is what she likes
what she doesn't like messing around my
face I heard you're the man to see with
a big schlong I feel like it's almost
like getting a very disingenuous
compliment though like would you want
that but that's how thirsty you are sort
of affection I want a high man to follow
me all day like Ramses hype man Ramses
is the best Ramses is number one like
it's it's kind of like someone to keep
you high so you could perform the best
you know what you could do for free is
you write all your own compliments you
could think of some really good ones the
ones that you want people to tell you
you can think of you doing really good
ones and you put them in those random
sentence generators on Google and just
have Google spit you back out your own
compliments and it's so good every time
cuz you're like that's exactly it's
different from like a person yeah one's
a hand job and ones masturbation oh I
love masturbating giving you a hand
you don't know what they're gonna do
like videos like we I don't know that
was unpredictable when you do your own
self you're predicting it yet you always
do that baby you know exactly what you
bought sure that's a waste time so you
know what compliments you wanna get yeah
like wait like I don't know which one
I'm gonna get you know I want to be
surprised I want to be surprised like I
didn't even know I [ __ ] felt great
about that basically you know huge I
wasn't draw names out of a hat you could
do that on Google where you just
separate them by lines so you can just
put sentences instead of names and then
you just pull it you just hit random
generator and then it's like you like I
like your haircut like how did you know
you never got surprise from a compliment
before like you never knew like like you
invite compliments leave people know
believe me when I said green looks weird
on you today
never I would never came over to your
house and they were like nice couch and
you're like oh really you like it too
man you got a good taste I had no idea
yeah because they compliment my couch so
I'm like okay yeah yeah
but as a surprise though to me I'm like
what about Steve when he tells you he
gives you : okay so I trust Steve and I
trust like friend groups but not like
random people complimenting me I'm
always like you trying to get it no not
real limits only matter to me if I if
they're my friends or family or if I
value their opinion exactly when it's
just a regular exchange I'm like [ __ ]
you I'm not at it I'm just like well
shut up take it with a grain of salt
just like haters you know how like
you're supposed to take haters with a
grain of salt it's the same thing you
can't like just take the random praise
and be like well this is true but these
haters are wrong it's like it's the same
[ __ ] I know what you mean
Vanessa told me this funny ass [ __ ]
story and when she went to junior high
right and you know the day before school
you or the day or a few days before you
get your outfit ready to go to school so
you could show up beforehand so she gets
her [ __ ] done she buys all her clothes
everything was [ __ ] poppin and then
she go to the school and the janitor
comes up to her says I like your outfit
we could've been a teacher it was the
fact an adult look at it was like your
outfits fly over I understand what you
mean she took it that way for me like
its although as a little [ __ ] 12 year
old like I understand why she did but
I'm just like there's no fashion he's
not a fashion expert I think you know
what happens is like you watch people
and you're like oh I don't like so
youtubers for example there was like
some people that are really big and then
all their comments are like oh my god
you're amazing you're so funny and
everything's great and you don't I don't
personally think that about them and so
I'm like well they're getting all these
compliments and I don't think that's
true so then when people do that to me
I'm like I don't think you're true
either like it could I don't have the I
don't know hey cuz for ya like I don't
know like for me it's because I try to
be as truthful as I can could you hate
lying
and I just like can never hide behind
like a fake lie right so because of that
reason every time I do call them and
someone it's I don't even see it as a
compliment is just like hey this is a
truthful time yeah this is the fact that
I really like how this looks on you but
that's in person right ya know and not
just that but like because of that
reason like just how you see it as that
way for the internet comments so you're
like well because I don't agree with
that I see it the opposite I'm like damn
is they say something nice about me or
if they actually say something mean
about me I believe it as truth because I
I guess in my mind I'm tricking myself
that everyone else's oh you're
projecting you ye how you act on to
everybody else I think there's also a
good way to do it too without like
telling people how you feel like for
example if there was a youtuber that I
met and I've seen their content before
and I think it's [ __ ] hot burning
garbage like and they come up and they
tell you they like your [ __ ] I'll just
be like yo man that's dope Thanks yeah
leave it at that I don't have to make a
comment I take that as an insult someone
makes a really bad content they come up
to me like - yo she's dope alright what
am I doing wrong
Oh Oh my god would happen he was
twisting ketchup for fun and exploded
anything but that's what there's a
certain youtuber like a few years ago
which content I absolutely hated and
this person didn't know why else to
giving me a compliment he also insulted
me because he said you know what our
contents are just the like in my mind I
was like you [ __ ] living piece of
[ __ ] don't you ever [ __ ] say that
thank you but don't ever say that in my
mind and they were much bigger than you
after oh they're still not uh-huh behind
that complement oh we're that compliment
came from
I also examine credibility - yeah so
it's like like let's say someone that
doesn't know how to cook and they say I
made something good on it thank you
it's like very surface you know but I
give like David or Joe or like a someone
that cooks really good and they tried
something I made oh man this is really
good I'm like it's actually incredible
yeah versus just [ __ ] because you
can't cook at all like he just warms
things up so if he tells me I didn't
even put the pizza no he didn't put the
pie on a like slip in the rack with
nothing falling wait where was this so
it was like the pastry just yeah because
I think he took it out I think it was
like a frozen writing you're supposed to
put it on a sheet you just put it
directly on the rack that's my baby
that's my seat the pizza in there I
married that man most time to fall
through yeah like it certain like dude
what did you do so try taking it out and
he was falling everywhere so beat
repetitively
you don't want to look inside our oven
yeah what's not Jay King is we're like
okay you start with bread come she goes
how I say what do you mean how he was
like what do we do with breadcrumbs how
do you do that you can finally get a
grater you start grating it this way I'm
like why are you making it more
complicated than it is
right brother bro you see bread crumbs
they fall off I've really bad be me
though I was like when dad takes care of
the kids and like when my dad took care
of us for dinner we got frozen broccoli
oh dude I would eat broccoli cuz I like
broccoli and like sometimes I would just
eat it because I didn't have that adults
around to cook it and I would just eat
the frozen broccoli so he thought oh she
likes that and so that's what he would
give me for dinner and I would eat it
because that's what was served to me and
then he'd be like oh my god this is so
easy I just give them frozen broccoli so
that's what he would do every time he
had to take care of malaria just frozen
broccoli into a ball and he's like oh
dinner left Korea two weeks we had eggs
over [ __ ] this pre-made you know that
vegetable packet fried rice thing yeah I
made that [ __ ] [ __ ] 14 days in a row
now we had to eat that [ __ ] and I came
back my mom showed what did you eat with
our dead [ __ ] fed us eggs and rice
all the time she goes she come back to
my Tyrion why don't you just [ __ ] buy
him a pizza
what's wrong with you it's good nobody
wants a this [ __ ] every day
this is [ __ ] start arguing yelling at
each other
[Music]